billy eilish stuns on the cover of
british vogue
rocking a whole new look which is so
incredible the 19 year old grammy winner
traded in her
signature baggy clothes and went all out
hollywood glam complete with corsets and
honey blonde
locks i mean i just think it's like
if it's something you you feel just like
do that
inside the mag billy opens up about her
new music
and her new look saying she feels quote
more like a woman somehow
and while she loves her new vibe the
ocean eye singer said
she anticipates that there will be some
backlash to her new style choices
quote suddenly you're a hypocrite if you
want to show your skin
and you're easy and you're a [ __ ] and
you're a [ __ ]
if i am then i'm proud me and all the
girls are hoes and
you know let's turn it around and be
empowered in that
showing your body and showing your skin
or not should not take
any respect away from you that's all i'd
say to be honest with you
billy echoed all that on instagram
sunday posting snaps from her shoot
alongside the caption quote i love these
pictures and
i loved doing this shoot do whatever you
want whenever you want
everything else gotta give it to him oh
and
get this billy's post on instagram
surpassed
1 million likes in just six minutes
making it the fastest pick to ever
achieve that on the platform
it's like so flattering so i appreciate
that in the article the writer mentions
a situation in which billy says she was
taken advantage of when she was younger
adding that quote
the details are hers once again billy
says she predicts the haters will come
after her for talking about that
experience in her music
while showing off more of her body
billy's response
quote yes i am [ __ ]
she says
billy opens up about an abuse of power
in her song
your power which dropped on friday in
the accompanying music video
the singer is seen bound tightly by a
large snake
[Music]
and if new music and a british vogue
cover aren't enough
it was also announced on monday that the
met gala will be returning after a
year's hiatus amid the pandemic
and billy will co-chair the event
alongside timothy chalamet
naomi asaka and amanda gorman
of course fashion has always been
important to billy
back in 2019 she told et about her
unique style that's always making waves
i like to be judged so i wanna i wanna
see heads look up
it's really sick it's kind of exactly
what i'd want people to care about you
know
yeah like i don't know the things that
the people sort of know me for are all
the things i want to be known for if
that makes sense because style has
always been something i care about